هذه الصور الخاصه من مدينه حارم السوريه
في ادلب وهي احدى المدن المتضرره جراء
الزلزال
نتبع هذه الصور حارم هي احدى المدن
المنكوبه في سوريا
وفي ادلب تحديدا حجم الدمار كبير للكثير
من المباني المتضرره جراء هذا الزلزال
مباني هدمت تماما سويت بالارض مباني اخرى
طالها ايضا الدمار الجزئي ربما فرق
الانقاذ المتوفره البسيطه كما نشاهد
المعدات كذلك الثقيله الموجوده على الارض
الان تقوم بجهد كبير في محاولات منها
لانتشال الجثث او مساعده العالقين تحت
انقاذ هذه المباني
المدمره في ضوء الارقام الاخيره ايضا
المرصوده حول
القتلى او المصابين جراءه هذا الزلزال
الذي دمر اجزاء كبيره من الجنوب التركي
ومن الشمال في سوريا
ينضم الينا الان السفير التركي لدى
السعوديه فاتح سيد فاتح اهلا وسهلا بكم
معنا
تعزينا اولا للضحايا
وكذلك للدمار الذي نشاهده الان يعني ربما
في هذه الصور من سوريا وكذلك من مناطق
كثيره في الجنوب
التركي سيد فاتح اولا كيف تم التنسيق مع
سلطات السعوديه في مساله هذا الجسر الجوي
الاغاثي السعودي